c'est la coït
donc Madame Messieurs mes chers
collègues madame la rapporteur nous
poursuivons cet après-midi les travaux
de notre commission d'enquête par
l'audition des représentants du
laboratoire nordique Pharma France
Monsieur Vincent Léonard président le
docteur madame le docteur Hélène Hermann
demain directrice médicale et
pharmacovigilance et Monsieur Nicolas
Doumen qui est pharmacien responsable je
vous remercie de vous être mobilisés en
un temps aussi bref il nous semblait
important bien évidemment de vous
entendre en urgence pour évoquer les
tensions d'approvisionnement qui
touchent actuellement le miso prostol ce
produit est notamment utilisé dans le
cas d'une interruption volontaire de
grossesse médicamenteuses et je rappelle
que les IVG médicamenteuses représentent
plus des trois quarts des interruptions
volontaires de grossesse environ en
France c'est dire si le misoprostol est
essentiel pour les femmes il figure
d'ailleurs parmi la liste des
médicaments essentiels de l'OMS
l'accès à ce traitement et est essentiel
pour garantir à chaque femme le droit de
disposer de son corps est nécessaire
pour que le recours à l'IVG dans des
conditions autorisées par la loi soient
effectivement à ce titre peu importe que
l'on parle de tension
d'approvisionnement comme la fée le
ministre de la santé ou de pénurie
puisque ce médicament est difficile à se
procurer dans plusieurs régions
françaises alors ça tourne et ça évolue
sur le plan géographique les hauts de
France et l'Île-de-France en particulier
la NSM a constaté officiellement une
forte tension d'approvisionnement le 7
février dernier et à par conséquent
interdit la vente et l'exportation du
miso one 400 par les grossistes
répartiteurs vers l'étranger ainsi que
par les distributeurs en gros vous nous
direz exactement quels sont les
spécialités concernées par ces tensions
ainsi que leur destinations officine ou
hospitalier
la perspective d'une pénurie durable et
donc extrêmement préoccupante à fortiori
puisqu'il n'existe pas de générique ni
de produits équivalents misoprostol les
possibilités de substitution de
prescription sont donc inexistantes
comment en sommes-nous arrivés là à bien
des égards la pénurie que nous
connaissons depuis plusieurs semaines et
symptomatiques de la situation de notre
industrie pharmaceutique alors que la
France a été pionnière dans la recherche
sur ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler la
pilule du lendemain nous ce qu'on
appelait ainsi au moment au moment de sa
sortie la disponibilité d'un des deux
médicaments utilisés pour accéder à la
forme la moins invasive et la moins
coûteuse de l'IVG est insuffisante dans
notre pays de plus la pénurie actuelle
n'est pas entièrement nouvelle car dès
2020 novembre 2020 des ruptures de stock
de courte durée étaient apparues sans
impact sur la santé publique selon le
ministre de la Santé de l'époque Olivier
Véran que nous entendons d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure plus près de chez nous en
décembre 2022 puis en février dernier le
Canada a enregistré des ruptures
d'approvisionnement également cela
interroge sur la capacité des pouvoirs
publics à réagir face à ces signaux
faibles autant que les tensions avant
que les tensions ne se transforment en
pénurie sur le terrain vous avez
semble-t-il informer la NSM de retard de
fabrication dès la fin de l'année
dernière vous voudriez vous voudrez bien
nous communiquer les raisons de ces
retards évidemment et leurs conséquences
concrètes sur la disponibilité de mise
au prostol en pharmacie en outre la
bataille juridique autour d'Olivier aux
États-Unis a conduit plusieurs États
notamment à la Californie a constitué
des stocks très importants de cette
spécialité afin de garantir son accès
sur plusieurs années et cette
incertitude perdure évidemment ceci pose
évidemment la question de sa
disponibilité sur les autres marchés
vous nous direz si se trouve dans une
situation particulière à cet égard
l'annonce par la NSM d'importation en
provenance d'Italie par étant effet le
démontré et nous interroge du reste sur
l'ensemble de ces huchets monsieur le
Président docteur monsieur je vous je
vais vous céder la parole pour un propos
introductif qui ne devra pas excéder 10
minutes répartis entre vous et comme
vous le souhaitez puis madame Laurence
Cohen rapporteur de notre commission
d'enquête vous posera une première série
de questions comme vous l'aurez compris
notre commission d'enquête en temps
obtenir des réponses étayées à des
questions et précises et à une situation
que nous vivons pleinement je précise
également que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des plaines
prévues aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous invite chacun à votre tour à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure monsieur Léonard
madame le docteur Hermann demain
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie de nous
donner l'occasion de nous exprimer sur
les tensions dans la chaîne
d'approvisionnement du misoprostol de
ces dernières semaines avant de répondre
à vos questions j'aimerais en quelques
mots très rapidement vous présenter
Nordic Pharma brièvement évoqué
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
mais vous l'avez déjà fait madame la
Présidente
afin de mieux comprendre le cadre dans
lequel le miso procès est utilisé avant
de vous partager bien sûr l'état de nos
stocks à aujourd'hui l'état de nos stock
à venir sur les deux molécules utilisées
dans l'IVG et vous éclairez sur les
tensions d'approvisionnement de
misoprostol de ces dernières semaines
alors très rapidement le laboratoire
nordique Pharma a été créé en 1995 en
Suède Nordic Pharma est un laboratoire
pharmaceutique à capitaux privés
européens je le précise d'emblée un
ordict Farman n'a aucun capital
américain comme on a pu le lire dans la
presse ou ailleurs on est un laboratoire
capitaux privé européen depuis 2001
nordique Pharma nordique se développe en
dehors de la Scandinavie grâce au
filiales de Nordic Pharma présente dans
toute l'Europe avec des activités
pharmaceutiques complètes que ce soit de
la production du développement clinique
ou l'enregistrement
pour ce qui concerne nordique Pharma
France la filiale a été créée en 2002
essentiel est situé au 216 boulevard
Saint-Germain juste à côté juste à côté
d'ici
l'ordi Pharma France est constitué d'une
soixantaine de collaborateurs
expérimenté expert de leur domaine et
nos activités sont concentrées sur la
rhumatologie l'anesthésie et ce qui
réunit nous réunit aujourd'hui la
gynécologie avec différentes molécules
et non marques mifigine mise au one et
jimiso ainsi que deux dispositifs
médicaux il y a le barrières et check-up
on nous avons réalisé l'an passé un
chiffre d'affaires de 50 millions
d'euros ce qui fait que nous sommes une
entreprise aujourd'hui de taille modeste
dans l'univers de l'industrie
pharmaceutique
donc effectivement nos domaines
d'expertise et la mise à disposition des
médicaments permettant l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse par voie
médicamenteuse que je me permettrai
d'appeler si vous voulez bien IVG Med
c'est dans le jargon beaucoup plus
rapide
merci
vous l'avez rappelé les chiffres en
France et 220 pardon 223
000 IVG qui sont réalisés par an et 76%
réalisé par voie médicamenteuse
par rapport à je tiens aussi à préciser
pour dans les chiffres à retenir que 68%
de ses avortements sont réalisés dans
des structures hospitalières ou des
cliniques
en France la le choix du recours à la
voix soit chirurgicale soit
médicamenteuse et laisser à la patience
pour la voie médicamenteuse elle peut
être pratiquée jusqu'à 9 semaines
d'aménorrhée et jusqu'à 14 semaines pour
la voie chirurgicale
notons que l'accès à l'IVG c'est
simplifié ces dernières années avec
notamment la suppression du délai de
réflexion et aussi la possibilité de
réaliser ces IVG en téléconsultation
concernant l'IVG médicamenteuse elle se
pratique avec deux médicaments
administrés à 48 heures d'intervalle
tout d'abord mifegine
la mi fait Preston et 48 heures plus
tard le misoprostol
miso one ou jimiso étant les deux noms
de marque
mais vous le connaissez certainement
mieux sous son nom de code le RU 486
qui parle en général beaucoup plus que
le nom de marque ou même le nom de
molécule et je tiens à préciser que sur
michigine il n'y a pas eu de tension sur
cette spécialité depuis les au moins les
24 derniers mois
concernant le misoprostol deux noms de
marque aujourd'hui mise au one et gimizo
historiquement le misoprostol était
disponible hors AMM mais le laboratoire
qui commercialisait cette molécule or à
elle-même n'a jamais voulu poursuivre le
développement et l'enregistrement dans
cette indication
IVG ce qui a conduit au retrait de ce
médicament en 2018
ce retrait a été rendu possible par le
fait que nordique Pharma a démarré la
commercialisation dès 2014 d'un
misoprostol au dosage adapté à l'IVG et
spécialement indiqué dans l'IVG
ce développement et cet enregistrement a
été rendu possible par la volonté des
dirigeants de Nordic Pharma de mettre à
disposition une cohérence de traitement
et surtout d'information médicale pour
les patientes et les professionnels de
santé
si aujourd'hui nordique pharmace
retrouve être exploitant des deux
marques de misoprostol disponibles en
France mise au one hygi miso c'est que
le laboratoire amring qui
commercialisait le Gym ISO c'est retirer
du marché français et n'a pas trouvé
d'autres repreneurs que Nordic Pharma
pour assurer l'exploitation de cette
molécule
la production bien que nordique Pharma
pardon exploite les deux marques jimiso
et miso one Nordic Pharma a souhaité
conserver les deux canaux de fabrication
distincts pour garantir justement une
alternative de production qui a démontré
son efficacité ces dernières semaines
l'usine de principe actif pour les deux
médicaments et la même elle est située
en Angleterre à côté de Newcastle
par contre pour l'usine de principes
actif par contre pour miso one les deux
usines qui vont intervenir en sa
fabrication sont basés en France
la première qui va fabriquer le produit
fini les comprimés et basé à Lille dans
les hauts de France et celle qui va
conditionner ses comprimés du côté
d'Auxerre donc on est sur une
fabrication
européenne et en grande partie française
pour Jim ISO c'est sur le site de Leon
Pharma en Espagne que les comprimés sont
fabriqués et conditionnés
par conséquent l'ensemble du process et
sous contrôle de Nordic Pharma et en
aucun cas l'approvisionnement ne dépend
de la situation
politiqueo-économique aux États-Unis
vous nous avez invité à venir
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la mission
de votre commission d'enquête sur les
ruptures d'approvisionnement vous l'avez
évoqué la différence entre tension ou
rupture je tiens tout de même à préciser
et nous y reviendrons qu'il n'y a pas eu
il n'y a pas à craindre de pénurie à
proprement parler de mise au prostol ou
ne fait pristone en France aujourd'hui
journal déjà présent vous rassurer sur
l'état de nos stocks
au 2 mai donc aujourd'hui
pour mifigine de présentation de 100 mg
boîte de trois comprimés on a en stock
aujourd'hui 54 833 boîtes pour être très
précis soit à peu près 4,9 mois de stock
pour MIF Égine 600 l'autre présentation
1800 à peu près un petit peu moins de
1900 boîtes disponibles soit 3,4 mois de
stock en fonction de l'écoulement
classique de ce produit
pour ce qui concerne le miso prostol la
situation de stock est aujourd'hui pour
jimiso de 35000 boîtes soit à peu près
un mois et demi dans le cadre d'une
consommation courante ce stock sera
porté à plus de 3 mois et demi avec l'un
exception de 60000 boîtes début juin
pour mise au one nous avons deux
présentations une boîte de 1 comprimé on
a là aussi 34 348 watts 34000 watts soit
plus d'un mois de stock
6400 unités supplémentaires seront
livrés 7 semaines ce qui portera notre
stock à peu près à deux mois de deux
mois d'utilisation et le stock sera
apporté à plus de 5 mois à la fin du
mois de juin
mise au one boîte de 16 comprimés
l'autre présentation de mise one reste
je le conseille très faible aujourd'hui
on a à peine 500 boîtes en stock 4000
boîtes seront livrées là aussi cette
semaine 800 boîtes à la fin du mois de
juin soit 4 mois de stock
les tensions sont donc aujourd'hui finis
seul subsiste pour être complètement
transparent un léger contingentement
quantitatif qui permet en fait de
limiter les commandes à 95% d'Honoré à
peu près 95% des commandes et ce
contingentement est fait pour éviter les
phénomènes de surtockage poste tension
d'approvisionnement qui pourrait être
fait
c'est ce niveau de stock qui a conduit
la NSM d'ailleurs à déclarer jeudi
dernier sur son site la remise à
disposition du miso one au niveau du
laboratoire
pour revenir à l'origine de ces tensions
qui était une autre de vos questions
ces tensions à la chaîne
d'approvisionnement je tiens à préciser
qu'elles sont totalement indépendantes
pour chacun des deux produits car comme
je vous l'ai dit nordique Pharma à
conserver les deux canaux de production
distincts
concernant le Gym ISO c'est un problème
de commande de principe actif entre le
site anglais et l'usine espagnole qui a
entraîné un décalage important dans le
planning de production et donc la mise à
disposition du médicament et à entraîner
une rupture vraie entre le 28 novembre
et le 16 janvier
depuis cette date un petit peu plus de
100 000 unités ont été réceptionnées les
reliquates commandes ont été livrés
permettant de pallier aux tensions
d'ailleurs qui ont suivi sur l'autre
misoprostol mise au one
pour le miso one c'est au niveau de
l'analyse du contrôle qualité que le
produit a été bloqué le temps de
comprendre l'origine de problème de
s'assurer de l'excellente qualité des
comprimés il s'est écoulé presque trois
mois entre février et le 26 avril
pour chacun de ces produits des mesures
ont été prises en totale transparence
avec la NSM
ces mesures ont consisté en des
contingentements pour éviter des sources
stockages à certains niveaux de la
chaîne d'approvisionnement et garantir
un écoulement plus régulier et
effectivement des importations de
produits destinés à d'autres marchés
européens notamment l'Italie
cependant comme la rappeler notre
organisme de tutelle la NSM la situation
a NSC pardon à nécessité toute son
attention et en concertation avec
nordique Pharma des mesures ont été
mises en place pour faire en sorte que
les toutes les patientes françaises
puissent bénéficier d'une prise en
charge
en conclusion dans ce dans un contexte
de rupture d'approvisionnement
rencontrées pour de très nombreuses
spécialités en France la gestion
conjointe ansm Nordic Pharma a permis
d'assurer la mise à disposition des
spécialités miso one et jimiso au cours
de ces dernières semaines et les plans
de production de 2023 nous confortent
sur les approvisionnements futurs
je vous remercie de votre attention et
nous sommes à l'écoute de vos questions
très bien merci beaucoup de ces éléments
je vais tout de suite passer la parole à
Madame Laurence Cohen rapporteur pour
une première étape de questions
merci monsieur le Président pour ces
explications donc je vais vous demander
un certain nombre de précisions on vous
en doutez parce que effectivement je
reste extrêmement dubitatif contenu des
alertes qui nous ont été rapportées en
tant que en tant que législaster que
nous sommes nous avons été alertés par
de nombreux associations féministes
notamment le planning familial par
l'Observatoire également de la
transparence des médicaments sur le fait
que il y avait une impossibilité pour un
certain nombre de patientes de pouvoir
recourir à une IVG médicamenteuse donc
si j'ai bien compris
les éléments que vous nous avez donnés
mais je vais vous les restituer pour
éventuellement lever mes doutes ou mes
interrogations les deux
si j'ai bien compris donc vous avez
parlé d'une rupture vraie entre le 28
novembre et le 16 janvier puis vous avez
parlé de trois mois qui ont été
nécessaires de février au 26 avril pour
vérifier la qualité du produit donc si
j'ai bien compris ça fait 5 mois 5 mois
pendant lesquels il y a eu au mieux des
tensions au pire une rupture donc ce qui
a entraîné des conséquences
concernant les demandes d'IVG
médicamenteuses pour les patientes
donc est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer ou
préciser ou infirmer ça c'est ma
première question deuxième question vous
avez parlé donc des deux produits
distincts
en précisant bien qu'il y avait deux
canaux différents
en même temps quand on a été alerté par
la presse alors est-ce que les les
informations étaient fondées ou pas
c'est à vous de nous le dire mais il se
serait agit d'une difficulté dans une
usine ou une chaîne de production
qu'en est-il de cette de cette
information est-elle réelle et telle
tronquée vous savez c'est toujours la
difficulté y compris pour les
législateurs que nous sommes y compris
au sein d'une commission d'enquête d'où
votre audition aujourd'hui à partir du
moment où on ne dispose pas d'éléments
nous nous informons comme tout un chacun
dans la presse et nous attendons des
confirmations ou pas donc deuxième
question troisième question
nous avons pu voir tout au cours de nos
de nos auditions depuis le début puisque
notre commission d'enquête se pend sur
la pénurie des médicaments donc un sujet
beaucoup plus large que celui que nous
abordons en ce moment avec avec vous
nous avons pu voir qu'il y avait un
souci y compris très très fort au niveau
des principes actifs que 80% des
principales actifs se trouvaient en
Chine ou en Inde
si j'ai bien entendu vos propos si je ne
les ai pas interprété vous avez
exprimé le fait que pour ces deux
produits il fait Jean misoprostol les
principes actifs se trouvaient
en Europe en France en Angleterre et en
Espagne donc ils ne sont aucun de ces
aucun de ses principes actifs ne se
trouve dans les 80% en Chine ou en Asie
est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer ou pas
ces éléments
par ailleurs autre série de questions
le fait que vous soyez
vous ayez le monopole en fait du du
du misoprostol fait que il ne peut pas y
avoir de produits génériques ni
d'alternatives médicamenteuse en Europe
ça pose donc un problème pour pour les
patients quand il y a j'allais dire je
vais lui dire comme ça un petit grain de
sable dans une usine de production ou
tout autre tout autre problème et
d'ailleurs ça a fait dire un certain
nombre de d'acteurs et d'actrices des
de santé que peut-être il fallait
réfléchir à ce que le gouvernement
français puisse avoir recours à la
licence d'office parce que au niveau des
produits comme les produits que vous
produisez
quand il n'y a pas même quand il y a un
petit des tensions qui peuvent durer un
mois ce qui peut paraître peu mais pour
une interruption volontaire de grossesse
ça peut être catastrophique parce que si
ça n'est pas fait dans les temps et bien
voilà
donc j'aimerais que vous puissiez nous
apporter un certain nombre d'éléments
qui nous permettraient d'être assurés ou
pas sur le fait que les patients
aujourd'hui et demain pourront
effectivement en France en Europe et
dans le monde mais enfin en tout cas ce
qui nous concerne au moins en France
pourront avoir bénéficier donc d'une
interruption volontaire de grossesse
médicamenteuse sans aucun problème
par ailleurs dans une autre série de
questions
vous toujours sur la position de force
que vous avez y compris sur la sur la
fixation du prix
quand
le se produit étant en tention nous
avons également eu vent de l'annonce qui
a été faite par la NSM de d'avoir une
importation en urgence de stock en
provenance d'Italie donc moi ce que je
voudrais savoir c'est est-ce que
finalement donc les tensions ou les
ruptures en France seraient dû un prix
qui serait plus bas que dans les autres
pays européens et qui feraient que
finalement les autres pays européens
seraient mieux servis que la France
et enfin dernière série de questions je
voudrais savoir le vous savez que le
gouvernement a annoncé ces dernières
années plusieurs initiatives que pour
garantir la souveraineté sanitaire de la
France et notamment assuré
l'approvisionnement en médicaments
essentiels est-ce que nordique Pharma a
pris par à ces discussions avec le
gouvernement à ce sujet précis est-ce
que votre laboratoire s'est porté
candidat aux appels à manifestation
d'intérêt ou d'appels à projet pour
bénéficier d'être public à l'innovation
ou à la réindustrialisation par exemple
dans le plan France relance ou de
finance 2030
alors si oui vous pouvez expliciter et
sinon pourquoi votre laboratoire ne
s'est-il pas porté candidat et puis
est-ce que vous pouvez également nous
dire de quelle aide publique vous
bénéficiez aujourd'hui ou avez-vous
bénéficié dans le passé pour justement
notamment les recherches et
développement et ou tout autre aide
publique dans le cadre des questions que
je vous ai posées précédemment je vous
remercie par avance
merci merci
madame le rapporteur pour toutes ces
questions on va essayer d'y répondre les
unes après les autres j'espère qu'on en
a pas oublié si jamais ça marche on fait
comme ça
donc vous avez été alerté effectivement
sur par le planning familial vous avez
évoqué trois mois puis deux mois donc 5
mois au total peut-être je suis mal
exprimé dans mon propos introductif mais
on parle de trois mois de rupture
effectivement pour le gYMISO donc une
marque de mise au prostol
et les deux mois que vous évoquez sont
pour l'autre marque de mise au prostall
d'accord ou là par contre ça n'a pas été
une rupture à proprement parler mais des
tensions et avec des contingentements
comme on l'a dit
un peu plus fort donc je vous confirme
effectivement une rupture sur les trois
mois pour le jimizo mais miso one était
en stock suffisant pour pouvoir
alimenter le marché l'autre misoprostol
l'autre marque de misoprostol et ensuite
deux mois sur Mise au one qui ont
effectivement été en tension Nicolas
peut-être que tu peux donner un peu plus
de précision sur ce qui a été mis en
place notamment pour gérer ces la
rupture de lin et les tensions de
l'autre
alors
tout d'abord pour reprendre ce que
disait monsieur Léonard le rapporteur
il n'y a pas eu effectivement de pénurie
à proprement parler en mise au prostone
au niveau du laboratoire
aujourd'hui effectivement nous avons agi
un tout transparence à les autorités de
santé et de santé
pour revenir à l'origine des primes
d'approvisionnement de chaîne
approvisionnement qui ont été rencontrés
concernant jimiso c'est en juin 2020 de
cunner humaine a été commise lors de la
commande de principes actifs
au niveau du site de fabrication de
produits finis cela a entraîné
effectivement un décalage de production
qui s'est fait ressentir au moment de la
campagne de production après l'été 2022
et à l'époque l'absence de contrat entre
les deux partenaires n'a pas permis de
prioriser une production suffisamment
tôt et amener un décalage à décembre
cette situation effectivement
dommageable
et depuis effectivement nordique Pharma
après la responsabilité gérer
l'intégralité des fournisseurs en stock
de principes actifs et de suspens de
référence pour les fabricants
concernant jimiso et comme c'est le cas
également pour mi-ovan depuis plusieurs
années nous faisons déjà cela pour vous
aurez compris pour mes ondes depuis
plusieurs années concernant les actions
mises en place des
identification des problématiques donc
en gros c'était des la fin septembre
ils ont été mis des en place des
contingentsment les contingents
progressifs qui ont été modifié au fil
de l'eau pour permettre de lisser les
commandes sur plusieurs mois cela n'a
pas permis d'empêcher une rupture
complète du produit jimizo entre le 28
novembre et le 16 janvier
c'est à peu près un mois et demi pendant
cette période il est important de
rappeler un peu plus d'un mois et demi
il est important de rappeler pendant
cette période les stocks de mise au
point n'étaient suffisants pour pallier
à cette à cette rupture
et le 16 janvier nous avons reçu un
premier une première vague de commande
de 26 000 unités de produits
puis alors nous avons maintenu également
des contingents pour limiter les risques
de surtockage à ce moment-là nous sommes
passés à des congènes contagionnements
qui nous permettaient de livrer environ
95% des commandes sans les modifier tel
quel
et également nous avons privilégié une
une
mise à disposition de
une mise à l'égression de jimmiso
exclusivement au niveau de la pharmacie
de ville avec une restriction
distribution et avant privilégier
effectivement les hôpitaux et la mise au
one boîte de 16 qui est une présentation
qui est dédiée et adaptée aux hôpitaux
le 24 février nous avons reçu 26000
unités supplémentaires soit 1,7 mois de
stock
vous en maintenus ce contagendement
hauteur de 95% des commandes honorées
et quatre avis nous avons reçu 46 000
unités supplémentaires soit 2,4 mois de
stock à ce moment là nous avons fait la
démarche de livrer l'ensemble des
grandes parties des reliquats de
commandes qui étaient en attente ce qui
a permis effectivement de lever les
problèmes sur gimizo
concernant je sais pas si pour les
choses vous paraissent claires je peux
passer la mise au one si vous voulez
bien concernant isovan
fin janvier nous avons identifié une
première alerte avec l'information d'une
non livraison fait de reliquats d'une
commande qui était attendue à ce
moment-là cette big boite plus
précisément de mise en mode 1 et une
information du fabricant d'indiquant
d'un décalage de la prochaine livraison
au mois d'avril nous devions
initialement être livré en mars nous
avons été ça devait être décalé en avril
début février la société delfarm qui
fabrique les comprimés nous a affirmé
d'un problème de ce problème de
contre-caillité dont on vous a parlé
monsieur Léonard
et nous avons également été informé de
l'arrêt de la fourniture des comprimés
par DELF auprès de Macor l'usine qui
fabrique les produits finis et qui
libère les lots
le retour normal était prévu pour le
mois d'avril et à partir de ce moment-là
nous avons mis en place un certain
nombre d'action pour limiter l'impact au
niveau du marché
notamment des actions de contingent dès
le premier le début février ce qui
concerne avec l'information faite à la
NSM de difficulté de tension sur ce
produit en voyant SMD le 7 février
puis
nous avons mis en mars nous avons
investigué à ce moment-là des pistes
d'importation pour apporter une sécurité
supplémentaire
pour l'approvisionnement du marché avec
notamment Sami boîte italienne qui était
disponible et qui permettait de
sécuriser la situation dans le 16 mars
nous avons fait l'ensemble des demandes
il va avril nous avons pu mettre à
disposition 1800 bottes italienne 24
avril 3200 boîtes supplémentaires et
ensuite comme prévu initialement et
échanger en toute transparence avec la
NSM dès le début nous avons reçu 26
avril donc soit fin avril les 38 000
unités qui étaient prévues correspondant
un peu plus trois mois de stock
bon les premières observés ont été
résolus les actions correctives ont été
mises en place au niveau de la gestion
de ces communs de principes actifs au
niveau du site de Leon ainsi que les
problèmes de contrôle qualité au niveau
du site de delfarm tout a été géré un
total transparence avec la NSM et en
tant que étant sur les raisons
implémentées pour éviter les
raisons que les actions implémentées
pour éviter les pénuries de mise au
prostol sur le territoire français
dans l'ensemble des actions nous ont
permis de mettre en place de s'assurer
qu'il n'y ait pas de tension sur le
territoire au niveau du laboratoire
qui est attention pas
j'espère qu'on vous a apporté des
éléments de réponse à votre première
question si vous voulez bien je propose
qu'on passe à la deuxième question qui
était sur les deux produits distincts et
vous mentionnez que la presse faisait
état de difficultés sur une chaîne de
produits je ne sais pas d'où vient cette
information j'espère qu'on vous a
apporté un peu plus d'éclaircissement
sur la fabrication je me permets
simplement de préciser que il y a deux
molécules
miphiles mais il faut quoi le fameux re
486 qui lui a son schéma de son canal de
fabrication et ensuite on préciser que
pour les deux misoprostols ce sont là
aussi deux canaux de production
distinctes
donc les raisons pour lesquelles on a
connu ces tensions sur le marché vous
ont été expliqués par par Nicolas pour
ce qui en est de ce qui a été évoqué par
la presse je me permettrai pas de
commenter au-delà
votre troisième question portait sur le
fait que 80% des principes actifs
étaient faits en Chine ou en Inde j'ai
reprécise à nouveau que l'ensemble de la
production pour les médicaments utilisés
dans l'IVG médicamenteuse sont fabriqués
en Europe
pour mifigine nous ne l'avons pas évoqué
puisqu'on parlait d'une mise au prostol
mais pour mifangine
la production est 100% française puisque
même le site de fabrication
du principe actif là il fait prétestone
et basé en France c'est l'usine PCs et
je ne sais plus dans quel coin de la
France elle est pour être complètement
transparente mais je sais qu'elle est
située dans l'Hexagone
et ensuite pour le misoprostol
effectivement l'usine de principe actif
et la même en Angleterre et ensuite un
site de production en Espagne pour le
géniso de site en France pour le miso
one
donc une particularité peut-être par
rapport 80%
. si vous voulez bien on enchaîne dans
les dans les questions si vous avez pas
de demande supplémentaire vous avez
évoqué effectivement le monopole je me
suis permis de dans mon propos
introductif vous expliquer comment
est-ce qu’on était arrivé dans cette
situation de monocopole vous dit que par
conséquent il n'est pas possible d'avoir
de générique ou d'alternatives
aujourd'hui le misoprostol n'est pas
breveté dans ces indications
c'est donc une situation de monopole
mais qui n'est pas lié à une
impossibilité d'avoir des génériques sur
ces produits
tout de suite il n'est pas breveté vous
avez dit dans cette application de
médicamentseuses ou donc pourquoi vous
avez pas vous avez précisé dans cette
application alors il y a d'autres
utilisations du misoprostol possible
avec un autre dosage dans une autre
indication je pense notamment à la au
déclenchement de l'accouchement
Hélène je sais pas si tu veux apporter
des précisions par rapport à ça mais
dans le oui mais dans l'autre parce que
je voulais dire je me suis mal exprimé
cette fois-ci donc dans l'autre enfin
dans les autres applications ou dans
l'autre application je sais pas s'il y
en a une ou plusieurs il est breveté ou
pas alors j'avoue que nous notre
commercialsons pas dans les autres
indications d'accord donc je ne saurais
pas vous répondre c'est certainement mon
confrère de des autres laboratoires qui
pourraient vous apporter ces précisions
après il y a d'autres utilisations du
misoprostol de jimiso et de mise au one
qui sont encadrées dans le cadre des CPC
le cadre de prescription compassionelle
peut-être Hélène tu peux nous donner les
deux indications oui alors dans le cadre
des CPC dans le cadre du cadre de
prescription compassionelle donc dès
2018 la NSA nous a demandé de mettre en
place des protocoles d'utilisation
thérapeutiques pour notamment deux CPC
la première étant
l'interruption médicale de grossesse et
la morphétale et nutero donc qui fait
l'objet d'une CPC et la seconde CPC est
la grossesse arrêtée jusqu'à 14 semaines
d'aménorrhée qui est la fausse couche
donc c'est CPC ces deux CPC sont dans la
pratique des professionnels de santé
depuis 2018 elles ont été renouvelées en
et récemment la NSM nous a aussi demandé
de mettre en place une troisième CPC
pour l'IVG médicamenteuse au-delà de 7
semaines d'aménorrhée donc pour les
diriger médicamenteuses 8 9 semaines
d'aménorrhée puisque nous il n'y a pas
d'AMM au-delà de cette semaine
d'aménorrhée donc pour régulariser cette
utilisation horaire aujourd'hui la NSM
avec Nordic Pharma
encadre dans le cadre de CCPC les toutes
les utilisations on va dire de du
mésoprostole et de la méfie Preston et
nous avons à rendre des comptes tous les
six mois à la NSM par des rapports sur
les données cliniques de ses patientes
puisque certaines des CPC font l'objet
de fiches de suivi et donc font l'objet
de rapport régulier et la NSM est au
courant tous les six mois et à la la
fois dans le cadre de ces rapports de
CPC et dans le cadre de la pharmacologie
de la pharmacovigilance de routine que
nous effectuons et qui est sous ma
responsabilité
chez Nordic Pharma
j'espère avoir répondu à votre question
merci merci Hélène par rapport au
monopole donc et vous évoquiez la
licence d'office un élément que je ne
maîtrise pas très bien mais qui
permettrait d'avoir des stocks de sûreté
si je reprends le terme il faut savoir
comme ça a été évoqué que le misoprostol
fait partie des médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur et en cela nous
oblige à un certain niveau de stock de
sécurité que Nicolas peut préciser
alors effectivement c'est spécialités à
base de mise au prostol sont identifiés
au niveau comme médicament d'Internet
thérapeutique majeur notamment en raison
de leur importance dans la prise en
charge de l'IVG médicamenteux à ce titre
font l'objet d'un suivi rigoureux
irrégulier tout au long de l'année afin
d'anticiper tout événement
à même d'impacter l'approvisionnement du
marché nous suivons par exemple
régulièrement les ventes les
consommations nous ont une veille
régulière une séance des micro signaux
en information médicale en
pharmacovigilance une variable nous
suivons également l'actualité sur l'IVG
nous savons qu'on soit conscience cela
peut avoir un impact aussi sur les
consommations
nous mettons en place suivant également
les états des stocks des grossistes et
mettons en place bien sûr des stocks de
sécurité mais également stocker d'alerte
qui me permet d'avoir une vision
supplémentaire
bien évidemment c'est une difficulté ne
veut pas être évitée nous avons sur ces
produits un plan de gestion de pénurie
l'objectif de ce plan de gestion de
pénurie et de réaliser une évaluation du
risque de survenue de difficulté l'âge
sur la chaîne approvisionnement et de
proposer des mesures pour limiter leur
survenu ou leur impact
les relations du risque notamment prend
en compte la pathologie traité dans
notre cas bien évidemment vous comprenez
on parle pas de pathologie mais plutôt
d'indication
la robustesse de la chaîne de
fabrication du principe actif et du
produit fini et les modalités
distribution de la spécialité sur le
territoire
afin de limiter la survenue des
difficultés et leur impact pour les
patientes pour les femmes nous pouvons
mettre en place différentes mesures donc
différentes mesures de contingentement
quantitatif ou qualitative dans notre
cas c'est ces mesures qui ont permis de
lisser
ce contingent de ma quantitatif qui ont
permis de lisser sur la longueur les
commandes sur la durée de la difficulté
nous pouvons mettre également en place
une certaine disposition de restrictions
de distribution c'est ce qu'on a mis en
place notamment en ville et à l'hôpital
notamment le gimizeau et le bottes une
qui ont été quand été mis en ville
préférentiellement et la boîte de 16 qui
a permis d'alimenter correctement les
hôpitaux
nous pouvons également avoir recours à
des alternatives c'est ce qui a été mis
en place alors c'est ce qu'on vous
expliquait tout à l'heure effectivement
sur miso one et jimiso il y a eu deux
périodes de difficultés différentes et
distinctes et à chaque fois un produit
amené à compenser les lacunes vous
pouvez avoir la distribution de l'autre
produit par exemple lorsque j'ai mis au
été en rupture mise one avait des stocks
suffisants pour commencer lorsque mise
au monde avait présenté plus de
difficultés sur la chaîne
d'approvisionnement nous avons été
amenés à privilégier ou à orienter vers
gymis ISO lorsque celui-ci était
disponible tout de suite chez les
grossistes par exemple auprès de
pharmacie qui nous appelait
on a été on peut être également amené à
chercher des alternatives à l'import
donc ça c'est effectivement ce
mouvementé tout à l'heure dans la
précédente sur la plantation des
produits d'Italie
c'est un élément supplémentaire de
sécurisation
l'ensemble de ces dispositions soit
également complétées par d'autres
dispositions au niveau industriel
notamment ce qui est important à retenir
pour mise au ban c'est qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons un stock tampon de substances
actives au niveau du site de fabrication
du comprimé ce stock tampon permet de
fabriquer environ un an de stock de
produits finis
qui est disponible tout le temps chez le
fabricant de comprimés la même manière
nous avons mis en place aussi un stock
tampon de comprimés
équivalent à un lot de fabrication au
niveau européen chez le fabricant de
chez le fabricants de produits finis le
site de conditionnement et de libération
du produit vous aurez compris
effectivement qu'il y a deux sites
distincts qui fabrique les comprimés
Macor qui
met en conditionnement et qui libère les
lots
donc ces dispositions sont une sécurité
supplémentaire
et pour jimiso suite aux difficultés
rencontrées nous ont mis en place aussi
un stock tampon de 30 kg de principes
actifs au niveau du site de fabrication
d'autres mesures d'optimisation sont
aujourd'hui en cours d'investigation
à moyen long terme notamment la
recherche de sites alternatifs qui est
une activité continue de notre côté la
consolidation aussi des sites existants
notamment le site existant pour mise au
one
ou bien la mise en place de solutions
pour améliorer le système de commande
des standards de référence et des
substances actives
donc aujourd'hui effectivement nous
interroger sur les stocks de sécurité
comme vous pouvez le constater on a mis
en place un certain nombre de batterie
de d'éléments de sécurisation qui nous
permettent d'anticiper toute
problématique
merci
si vous n'avez pas d'autres questions
sur ce point je on peut passer la
question suivante qui était relative au
prix du médicament donc premier point et
vous l'avez compris je l'espère c'est
que les problèmes d'approvisionnement de
ces dernières semaines n'a aucun rapport
avec le prix du médicament lui-même
l'importation de produit italien a été
fait comme la évoqué Nicolas parce que
le stock était disponible en Italie et
qu'on pouvait rapatrier ce stock en
France sans porter préjudice justement
aux femmes italiennes qui étaient en
souhaits d'avoir un avortement
médicamenteux le stock était suffisant
pour le faire
pour ce qui concerne le prix pour être
précis la boîte d'un comprimé de mise au
one comme la boîte de jimmizo sont
toutes les deux au même prix à 10 euros
65 ce qu'il faut savoir dans le cadre de
ces médicaments dans le cadre de l'IVG
c'est que les prix ne sont pas
réglementés selon la réglementation de
droits communs les prix sont libres et
remboursés sur la base d'un forfait
Nordic Pharma a toujours vendu et a fait
le choix de vendre ses produits au
montant de prise en charge du forfait
nous n'allons pas au-delà même si le
prix est libre
c'est une volonté
de nordique de de maintenir
effectivement le prix au niveau de la
prise en charge de ce produit
par ailleurs la France et un marché
prioritaire pour ces médicaments à
savoir que la France représente à peu
près 60% des ventes de mise au one et
91% des ventes de gimso donc ces
problèmes d'attention
d'approvisionnement non par rapport avec
le prix de médicaments lui-même sachant
qu'en France le prix du médicament pour
les médicaments pour l'IVG est un peu
particulier
il est pris dans le cadre du forfait
Hélène peut-être si tu veux n'importe
quel précisions sur le montant du
forfait alors vous êtes peut-être au
courant que le
l'IVG médicamenteuse en ville à un
forfait et les végé médicamenteuses en
réaliser en établissement de soins
hôpitaux ou clinique à un autre forfait
mais donc ce forfait est varie
évidemment dans le cadre d'une IVG
réalisé en ville le forfait est à 183
euros 57 et ou 188 euros 81 selon le
souhait du médecin de réaliser une
échographie préalable à la réalisation
de l'IVG
dans ce forfait il y a le forfait il y a
la part du médicament et la part du
médicament est à 10 euros 65 que le
l'IVG soit réalisé en ville ou que l'IVG
soit réalisé en établissement de santé
en établissement de santé bien sûr le
forfait est un peu plus élevé compte
tenu de la prise en charge dans la
structure hospitalière le forfait est
fixée à 280 euros
282 euros 91 après on va pas rentrer
dans d'autres types de pratiques de
l'IVG puisque là nous sommes focus sur
l'IVG médicamenteuse et donc vraiment le
prix du médicament c'est 10 euros 65
quel que soit le lieu où est réalisé
l'IVG
merci Hélène donc une fois encore aucun
rapport entre le prix du médicament et
les tensions d'approvisionnement
auxquelles on a été confronté ces
derniers ces derniers temps
et puis dans la dernière série de
questions vous évoquez effectivement des
initiatives pour garantir la
souveraineté
la souveraineté nationale
et vous souhaitiez savoir si nordique
Pharma est pris par à ces initiatives
nordiques Pharma est un acteur comme je
vous l'ai dit de taille modeste de
taille de taille modeste nous n'avons
pas levé la main je dirais pour prendre
part à ces initiatives une fois encore
j'espère qu'on a réussi à vous démontrer
que nos produits sont fabriqués pour une
grande partie en France 100% pour
mifangine
une grande part pour mise au one et
sinon ils sont réalisés en Europe donc
on est on est quand même sur une
approche très très pas entrée locale et
très franco-française
là-dessus par rapport aux aides
publiques auxquelles nordiques Pharma
aurait pu avoir eu recours aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas d'aide publique pour
nos travaux de recherche et
développement Nordic Pharma a dû faire
appel à des crédits d'impôt recherche il
y a quelques années pour partir sur sa
gamme de rhumatologie donc aucun rapport
avec
ce qui nous ce qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui et de mémoire je n'ai pas
souvenir qu'il y a eu d'aide de type C
hier sur
mi-fi ou miso one de mémoire mais
n'ayant pas vos questions avant je suis
pas c'est pas une élément qu'on a qu'on
a screené avant de venir on pourra
éventuellement si vous le souhaitez vous
apporter une réponse par la suite
je crois que nous avions couvert
toutes vos séries de questions s'il y a
d'autres questions très bien je suis
passé merci beaucoup j'ai passé la
question de mes collègues Laurence
non mais vas-y je te donne la parole
merci Madame le présidente mesdames et
messieurs merci beaucoup je dirais que
c'est un peu réjouissant de vous
entendre parce que par rapport à toutes
les auditions que nous avons eu
c'est franco-français c'est une pénurie
qui n'est pas liée à au prix du
médicament mais bien vous avez expliqué
une difficulté technique on vous entend
on vous croit bien sûr et et le prix du
médicament
voilà il est il est correct vous l'avez
précisé il ne change pas alors moi
j'avais préparé des questions et dans le
sens en me disant oui est-ce que
c'est le prix comme Madame la rapporteur
qui a donné
qui a provoqué l'attention parce qu'on
nous répète souvent que en France le
médicament ne sent pas payés assez cher
et que c'est les tensions sont dans ce
sens là vous n'avez pas eu de pénurie
sur les autres spécialités que la
gynécologie
c'est une question là on parlait que de
la gynécologie est-ce qu'il y avait de
la pénurie sur vos autres la
rhumatologie ou autre chose et quel est
votre vous avez parlé d'une production
qui est en consommation française vous
exportez quel est votre part
d'exportation elle est assez réduite
d'après ce qu'on a entendu et est-ce que
vous vendez au même prix
parce qu'on parle souvent du coût du
médicament trop bas en France
mais c'est le coût à l'unité or on peut
avoir un très gros chiffre d'affaires
dans un endroit et même si le cou est
bas à l'unité donc c'est intéressant de
connaître vos chiffres d'affaires
par pays où vous exportez ou vous vendez
merci
merci Madame pour votre question
avant de
merci madame le Président de ça va dans
le même sens que que Laurence sur cette
histoire de prix parce qu'il me semble
avoir entendu de votre part nous avons
fait le choix de de ne pas augmenter le
prix et d'avoir un prix qui
correspondait au remboursement donc la
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
c'est c'est rentable quand même je veux
dire que c'est pas ça veut bien dire que
le prix
se prit il est économiquement
acceptable pour pour vous et puis dans
le sens de ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure est-ce que vous avez eu d'autres
parce que là vous avez géré alors on
vous entend on a bien compris que vous
avez dit plutôt gérer une tension qu'une
pénurie c'est c'est les termes qui
avaient corrigé le ministre de la Santé
à propos de de ces médicaments et est-ce
que vous avez vous avez vécu enfin connu
autre type de tension comme ça
ou pas
donc moi je vais compléter est-ce qu'à
votre connaissance il y a eu des
décalages de prise en charge
thérapeutique lié à quand même ce qui a
été qualifié de pénurie alors j'entends
bien évidemment
on est un peu confronté à cette
situation de
l'utilisation du terme pénurie hors
tension tension sur une pilule abortive
dans les faits ça fait des arbitrages un
peu compliqué sur le terrain donc je
pense que on met les tensions et les
pénuries à peu près au même niveau même
si du point de vue industriel c'est pas
la même chose il n'empêche que en
pratique dans les faits c'est la même
chose quand on doit décaler ou ne pas
prendre en charge
et donc est-ce que est-ce que est-ce
qu'on voit c'est que donc on a des
chiffres nationales donc tout ça revient
la NSM dit on a une tension des pénuries
c'est d'ailleurs le propos que vous avez
tenu mais il y a la vraie vie il y a ce
qu'on appelle le chevelu du territoire
c'est à dire quand on arrive dans les
pharmacies quand on arrive sur le
terrain quand on arrive dans les
hôpitaux et on voit bien que les
remontées elles se sont faites de
certains cabinets
de certaines cliniques de certains
hôpitaux de certaines pharmacies on a
même évoqué des villes on a parlé de
l'île par exemple alors c'est vrai que
il y a des gens peut-être plus ou moins
vigilants ou plus ou moins en veille
plus ou moins réactifs peut-être en
fonction des lieux il n'empêche que
j'aimerais savoir si voilà il nous a
témoigné de décalage quand même de prise
en charge donc est-ce que vous avez la
confirmation que c'est décalages ont eu
lieu quand même dans un certain nombre
de cas puisque finalement on parle de
pays médicament et de médicaments
essentiels pour tout un tas de raisons
critiques c'est dire parce que la chaîne
de fabrication fait qu'on est à la
détention là le sujet c'est que il y a
pas d'alternative et que c'est un combat
pour les droits des femmes voilà et que
donc la question de se pose même pas
d'être dans la moindre situation de
fragilité
il y a pas de plan B voilà et c'est même
essentiel pour défendre des avancées en
matière en matière de droit donc c'est
voilà c'est cette question elle est elle
est assez précise quoi est-ce que ça ait
lieu est-ce que ça a pas eu lieu et bien
de par votre le rôle particulier de ce
traitement
il faut évidemment des mesures
particulières
Hélène Hélène avait tout prévu comme
bien souvent d'ailleurs
je vais reprendre les questions la
question qui angoissante
non je crois que c'est un virus qui
traîne depuis une semaine
bon je vais reprendre peut-être les
questions dans l'ordre la question de
madame la sénatrice il y a plusieurs
reprises vous avez évoqué que nous
tenions le même discours et les propos
qui avaient été repris par le ministre
de la santé sachez que toutes ces
tensions d'approvisionnement
ont été gérés en total transparence et
en total régularité avec la NSM ce qui
explique certainement pourquoi les
discours sont sont semblables ou en tout
cas fortement cohérents
donc effectivement par rapport à vous
nous posez la question de savoir si on a
vu d'autres pénuries sur d'autres de nos
gammes thérapeutiques
il peut arriver effectivement qu'il y
ait des décalages en rhumatologie
notamment sur sur nos dispositifs
d'injection par exemple mais là encore
pour des problématiques industrielles
pour nos autres gammes de rhumatologie
notamment en rhumatologie l'ensemble de
notre production et là aussi réaliser en
Europe
principale actif en Belgique pardon et
les chaînes d'assemblage des dispositifs
d'injection pour une partie en Belgique
pour une autre partie dans notre usine
qui appartient à la à notre maison mère
en Suède donc là encore on est sur un
dispositif européen donc on n'a pas on
n'a pas eu cela à gérer pour ce qui
concerne les parts de marché je crois
que c'était votre question par rapport à
l'exportation il faut savoir que sur
miphigine
RU486 je crois que ça parle à tout le
monde
la France représente un tiers des ventes
de ru de mifegines pour l'ensemble des
ventes de Nordic Pharma
et la France représente 65 % des
quasiment deux tiers des ventes de mise
au one quant à jimiso c'est un c'est un
produit je dirais quasi exclusif France
puisque 91% des ventes de gym ISO je
parle en unité en chiffre d'affaires à
chaque fois 91% des ventes sont
réalisées sur le territoire national
donc on est sur vraiment un produit à
forte dominante française
il me semble madame que la sénatrice que
vous aviez repris on va essayer de
terminer avant que tu ne meurs vous
aviez repris effectivement les questions
de madame vous me posez la question de
savoir si c'était un médicament rentable
je n'irai évidemment point trop dans le
détail pour le nom du secret industriel
ce produit
effectivement c'est nordique Pharma qui
souhaite ne pas dépasser le
remboursement du encadre du forfait ce
serait complètement possible une fois
encore mais notre volonté est de le
faire et nous allons même jusqu'à
étiqueter le nos boîtes avec le prix de
vente que l'on souhaite qui est une qui
n'est pas une garantie mais qui est un
souhait d'afficher effectivement notre
volonté de ne pas dépasser le cadre du
forfait quant à rendre la rentabilité
vous évoquez tout à l'heure madame la
rapporteur le monopole
une fois encore un monopole qui est de
circonstance qui n'est absolument pas
lié à un brevet je pense que ça répond
en partie à la rentabilité du produit
et enfin
la dernière série de questions était
au niveau du décalage de prise en charge
excusez-moi très concrètement on a les
niveaux de l'impact que ça a eu au
niveau du terrain que l'on a mesuré par
les appels et je vais laisser Hélène qui
est en charge de l'information médicale
de partager des chiffres
alors pour être tout à fait transparente
comme nous leçons nous sommes depuis le
début et en tant que responsable de
l'information médicale nous suivons bien
sûr tous les appels ils nous
enregistrons tous les appels des
professionnels de santé jour et nuit 365
jours par an 7 jours sur 7 donc nous
sommes d'astreinte tout le temps et tout
est enregistré et tous les matins tout
je regarde tous les registres et mon
équipe m'a l'alerte sur des éventuels
quotas qui dépasserait l'habituel
et donc sur l'année 2023 pour vous
donner très précisément les chiffres sur
les quatre premiers mois de l'année
nous avons reçu je parle des appels
concernant la logistique donc des appels
essentiellement de formation ou
éventuellement d'établir de formation de
ville ou pharmacien hospitalier qui nous
aurait appelé pour des problèmes de
logistique en janvier nous avons reçu
cet appel
en février nous en avons reçu trois
en mars nous en avons reçu 11 et en
avril nous en avons reçu 22
donc ce qui fait un total de 43 appels
sur un échantillon de 12 000 pharmacies
en France
en France c'est juste pour vous donner
un ordre de grandeur de du nombre
d'appels que nous avons reçu au
laboratoire nous n'avons pas eu à mettre
en place un numéro vert comme le monde
le Code de Santé Publique
vu la cette
volumétrie qui nous est apparue faible
pour vous donner un ordre de comparatif
sur l'année 2022 donc là nous sommes à
43 appels sur les quatre premiers mois
de l'année 2024 j'ai fait un check juste
avant de venir ici
vous rencontrez mon département n'a
rencontré plus aucun appel depuis le 25
avril
concernant la logistique donc qui est la
veille de la communication de la NSM sur
le retour
public des stocks de la communication
qui a été faite publiquement par la SM
le 26 avril et pour finir mon propos sur
l'année 2022 des appels concernant la
logistique ce sont élevés sur l'année
totale au nombre de 19
voilà c'est juste pour vous donner là
des c'est des appels de professionnels
de santé de pharmacie ville totale
concernant la logistique
et un point important aucune patiente
pour nous dire qu'ils étaient dans la
détresse
de la non d'un report de réalisation
d'une IVG
voilà donc là vous êtes à 43 et vous
avez eu 19 en 2022
sont des pharmacies des petites
pharmacies des grosses unités enfin
c'est parce que alors c'est pas tant le
nombre d'appels que
l'effectif que ça couvre
il y a deux éléments par rapport à il y
a deux éléments par rapport à cela
le premier étant que d'abord nous ne
sommes qu'un maillon dans la chaîne
d'approvisionnement qui englobe aussi
les grossistes les centrales et puis les
pharmacies
et notamment justement sur les
pharmacies et puis ce qu'on a pu lire
par ailleurs et je ne sais pas comment
d'ailleurs c'est remonté ont été faites
toutes les pharmacies en France ne
commandent pas de façon régulière du Gym
ISO et du miso one et donc je pense que
c'est un élément peut-être qu'on peut
sur lequel on peut revenir
on peut apporter effectivement en
éclairage ce qu'il faut savoir
effectivement c'est que nous
approvisionnons sans distinction
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'achat
d'approvisionnement et que comme disait
Vincent les grossis les pharmacies mais
il ne peut pas être exclu que certaines
agences de grossistes localement il y a
eu quelques difficultés à s'alimenter
ponctuellement en quantité suffisante ou
en raison de délai plus long de commande
mais dans tous les cas effectivement
nous avons tout mis en place pour
pouvoir pallier c'est à dire que nous
avons répondu aux demandes de dépannage
systématique des pharmacies on a eu sur
l'année notamment sur depuis le début de
l'année 1400 demandes de dépannage qui
ont été faits directement par les
pharmacies et auxquelles nous avons
répondu
on a du mal à confronter les 43 appels
et les Mickael 1400 dépannage
il y a un gros différentiel simplement
en fait les 1400 se sont fait au niveau
de notre plateforme de distribution
d'accord qui est l'intermédiaire
le dépositaire dégrossistes donc ça ce
sont les 1400 le chiffre qui est fait là
effectivement notre dippositaire a
systématiquement systématiquement pardon
répondu à la demande les 43 appels
correspondent à des appels directement
au laboratoire
au Département d'information médicale
donc ce sont les deux remontées
différentes 43 voilà les 43 en fait vous
éclaire plus précisément sur votre
demande qui était au niveau des
décalages et des impacts des patients
via leur professionnelle de santé les
1400 sont plus sur la gestion de ces
tensions dans la chaîne
d'approvisionnement
très rapide
dans la continuité du Maillon vous
livrez partout en Europe
vos médicaments est-ce que la pénurie
était pareil vous avez eu des remontées
de pays comme l'Allemagne ou autre de
manque de ces médicaments là ou c'est
vraiment franco-français alors ce n'est
pas exclusivement franco-français
puisque vous avez bien compris que c'est
tension d'approvisionnement étaient
liées aux chaînes de fabrication
simplement les effets se sont fait un
petit peu plus ressentir sur la France
que dans les autres pays de par les
parts de marché que je partageais tout à
l'heure où la France étant
prioritaire enfin majoritaire en termes
de parts de marché évidemment le
retentissement était plus important chez
nous que chez les autres
je sais pas
merci beaucoup de ces réponses très
complètes et précise
et voilà le rôle particulier joué par ce
traitement particulier
mérité qu'on est cette édition merci
beaucoup à vous merci de votre attention